Mark: Ethan get your ass in here.
Ethan: My ass?
Mark: Smack that ass for the thing.
Ready?
*smacks*
Ethan: Haha
*Mark smacks again* Ethan: Wow. *another smack*
O U C H
Mark: Once upon a time
Mark: In an old English country...
Mark: ...of Scottsdale, Arizona
Mark: There was a man who dreamed a dream
Mark: To take the previously made invention of pancakes
Mark: and turn it into something incredibly new and interesting and zesty
Mark: He made Mickey Mouse which wasn't to be invented for another 400 years
Mark: Into a pancake shape
Mark: And with that he created a new era
Mark: of pancake consumption, which was
Mark: a time-honored tradition among the Pagans of Eastern Europe
Mark: So from then on, we decided that it was time for us
Mark: To revive this lost art of pancake art
Mark: ...but I can't do it alone.
Mark: I need my friends
Mark: or
Mark: whatever is nearest and will do to substitute friends
Mark: Tyler 'The Apocalypse' Scheid
*aggressive spatula smack on table*
Mark: Known for his devastating flipping capabilities
Mark: If he were to flip at 100% capacity
Mark: he would annihilate the entire universe
Mark: ...and cause untold destruction across the land
Mark: He was known once
Mark: to flip SO hard
Mark: it cracked the very crust of the ocean causing
Mark: untold destruction!
Mark: You remember Noah's Flood?
Mark: PFFTT
Mark: More like Tyler's fist
Mark: And ALSO!
Mark: Ethan 'The Crust' Nestor
Mark: If you were to even question anybody
Mark: Who has the greatest, crispiest, goldenest crust
Mark: IN THE WORLD
Mark: It would be Ethan
Mark: There is no telling to how good that crust could be
Mark: Contents of the pancakes aside, it might be bad,
Mark: The crust, the flakiness, the bitterness
Mark: the crispiness.
Cannot be beaten on any scale
*Mwah *
Mark: And you may be wondering who I am
Mark: among these TITANS of pancake!
Mark: Well...
Mark: I can't believe you don't recognize me
Mark: Maybe not with this face
*proceeds to rip off face*
Mark: It's me, Markiplier
Mark: Mark...
Mar- Mark, 'Mr. Butterworth' Fischbach
Mark: Oh yes, it's true.
Mark: If you were wondering what made
*laughs*
Syrup so thick and juicy,
Mark: It was all 100% me baby *barely contained snickers*
Mark: From
*all laugh anyways *
Tyler: *laughing* How do you not not laugh?
Mark: Do you know why there's a national recycling program for these?
Mark: Cause they sent it to my house for refilling. *laughter*
Mark: Yet covering every single pancake out there in existence
Mark: it's 100%
Mark: me.
*Tyler and Ethan laughing*
Mark: so let's get started with this trio of perfection how can things go wrong
ONLY WHEN WE'RE PITTED *bang* AGAINST *bang* EACH OTHER
Mark: In Mortal Kombat
Mark: Yes *slam* each in our own right legendary among the pancake professionados
Mark: but we are here to bring this home to another level of pancake
Mark: We're gonna take your suggestions,
Mark: and your suggestions alone,
Mark: to make the greatest, best, fantasticist
Mark: mysticalest pancakes in existence
Mark: And who-M-soever
Chica: *WOOF*
Mark: Makes-
*silence*
And WHOM-soever makes
the greatest, best, most accurate pancake to your desires
WINS
So let's get started
SHALL WE? Shant we?!?
Ethan: We shall *smack*
Mark: We shall (2x)
We're going in RAW
Un*giggle*protected
We're not using recipes!
We're not using measuring cups!
We've been doing this for THOUSANDS of years
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT TO DO WITH THESE INGREDIENTS HERE
To make the best pancake possible
And you may be wondering "Uh! Where's the spoons?" *chuckle*
*clattering of spatulas*
*silence*
These are mah spoons.
*everyone repeating "spoon" over and over*
Mark: These are my spoons!
*everyone again repeating 'spoon' with a variety of poses*
Mark: Each of us will have 3 minutes to make the best batter that we can.
NO BUTTERMILK here unfortunately!
Don't know why no one's wanting me to make buttermilk pancakes they don't want me to *slam* WIIIN!
Count it down!
Kathryn (Off camera): 3
Go!
*various pouring, spraying, and other kitchen noises*
Mark: Usually as my dad would have done this he would have put this in the fridge overnight
uhh you know to fully mix and you know rise a bit, but
*high pitched voice* you know we're goin without it!
we're going a little bit you know off the uhh off the farm
TWO EGGS *Ethan very high pitched 'Ha!"* more like... more like the 'Incredulous'
*lots of banging* Scheid
uhhh there we go
whoaa
sorry for oiling your pit there.
Ethan: *odd accent* Ahh, it's fine dude!
Mark: *weird surfer accent* it's fine, dude! I got oily pits for days dude!
Alright so as you can see my opponents here unintelligibly went for two eggs??
uhh when *transitions into 'Snotty  Rich Kid' / 'Know It All' accent* obviously you should only use one egg
you don't want to *ethan squeak*
You don't want too gluey a pancake the more pro-ein you have in there the more it's gonna stick
You want a fluffy pancake you gotta go light on the mix
Markiplier is set to 'Low' and 'Oh Fuck God Stop' -those are my settings
How's the time?
Kathryn: You have... 1:10
Mark: EASY
Ethan: cha
Mark *scottish accent*: We got this
Mark *surfer accent*: Cha Cha Cha
Ethan: We used to make pancakes in our sleep
Mark: So you may be wondering "Oh this doesn't seem so bad!"
Oh, we're going to be judged on taste,
composition, and accuracy to the prompt.
*normal voice* That's how we're going to be judged
Ethan: *flirtatiously* May I taste your batter?
Mark: No
Ethan: One finger?
Mark: Not at all
*Stir stir stir*
You can't taste my batter on a boat, you can't taste my batter on a moat!
Tyler: Ethan!
NO (Pfft... Good job)
*Everyone laughs at Ethan*
Mark: Oh no, too much shoog!
Oh thats a good squeeze sugar *alarm*
Alright! Spoons down !
SPOONS DOWN!! *ethan lightly screams*
Tyler: Alright, I think I made the most batter!
Mark: *"swedish/french/russian" accent* Yeah, that's not the best batter...
Tyler: It's the very most!
Mark: It's about being quality over quam-nity.
Tyler: Well you need to food color it!
Mark: Yeah just like with YouTube it is not about quantity of videos, it's about quality!
*Ethan sound*
That's the Markiplier w-
Tyler: Okay do we get to wash our hand now?
Ethan and Mark: NO
Mark: *accent* WHAT ARE YOU STUPID?!
WITH YOUR STUPID HAT?!
Ethan: What, have you never made pancake before?!?
Mark: Have you never made pa- dooooooon't you dare
Mark: Put that the back in your bowl, bitch
Batman: *Batman voice* Batman doesn't take no crime
Batman: Batman won't take it- NOOOO
Mark: Who's ready for this?
Ethan: I'm ready!
Mark: So. We'regonna- BRING IN THE SQUEEEZE!!
*silence*
*accent* So, Tyler needs the girthiest boautles.
We get, you know, conservative go-flow ocean bottles.
Tyler: Are you sure I can't go wash now?
Mark: NO!
You wipe!
Oh, oh, a-wipe the big boy!
Oh my god, that was, like, /exactly/ my dick *everyone giggles*
So, we've also got fEUWd coloring
For, uh, psh, stupidity
Dunno why that's there
Pfft, whoever had that idea was a dum- BRING IN THE GRIDDDLEEEEEEEEEEEEE!!
*silence*
No, not you.
Ethan: Oh- well- sorry
Should we spray it down? Give it a good spritz?
Mark: Spray yourself, you bitch.
*Pam Spray being shook*
Ethan: Should I spray it? Give it a good spritz? Mark: Yo- You ar- *wheeze* *laughing*
Mark: We're totally repeating?
Mark: Yes Ethan, spray it! You are the crust after all, woah.
This is why he's a master!
Oh my God, Jesus Christ
Tyler: That is so much
Ethan: *snifts* Aah
Mark: This is why he's the master. If you question the master,
you get bit in the ass; that's the deal.
If you like getting bit in the ass, ask a lot of questions. If you don't
*whispers* then shut the fuck up.
Alright, so what we need is we need your suggestions
right now. Write in the comments right now!
Tyler: No we have to color first
Ethan: Color?
Tyler: Color our batter.
Mark: I'm not coloring until it gets on the griddle.
Ethan: mhm!
Mark: Where's my spatch!? Give me spatch. Here's your spatch!
Ethan: Thank you
Here's my spatch
Ethan: *drops spatula* Shit
that's Tyler's spatch
*accent* Don't toauch. Don't touch his spaouch
Ethan: Touch tip?
Mark: Touch tip
Our ti- No! *Mark noise* forbidden lauve
Ethan: *quiet echo* forbidden lo- *kisses spatch*
Aw fuck yeah! Oh fuck casual sex is great! :D
Alright! It's back on
We've got our squeeze. We've got to squeeze real good
If we don't squeeze good we die!
Ethan: Ready? Let's do one squeeze together, ready? Mark: No
Ethan: No? ok
Mark: You squeeze by yourself
*sad Ethan squeeze*
Back in 1824 there were 13 people in the
s-small town of Salem, Oregon ... they thought someone was
a witch because they made a pancake art just in the
exact representation... of Satan himself!
*Ethan spits* yes sizzling with anticipation
they- they cast the witch into the local lake. This... and- but
as soon as she touched the water
suddenly and the entire lake turned
to syrup and *giggling* THIS is how the most famous witch
of all, *laughs* Mrs. Butterworth, came into being.... *giggling again* alright lets go
Kathryn: Courage the Cowardly Dog
Mark: We're just rolling into that *ethan noise* after that bullshit story?
Ethan: Yeah, we are. (Mark: No let'ssnot!) Bullshit story? that was a- guh... that was a
Mark: That's my wife!
Ethan: *mimics, laughing* That's my wife!
Mark: Let's do this.
Ethan: Ready?
Mark: Courage
Ethan: the Cowardly
Mark: By who?
Ethan: ee..uh... the former stinson
Ethan & Mark: Ready,
Ethan: set, g- bombs away!
Mark: Bombs away!
*sizzling*
Tyler: Oh that's not good. I really hope I remember what Courage the Cowardly Dog looked like
Ethan: *laughing* He looked like a fucking dog
Tyler: He didn't look like a "fucking dog"
Ethan: What do you mean "He didn-?!"
Tyler: I watched the freaking show.
Mark: He's pretty much like a fucking dog if I'm not- If I'm
If I'm to be mistaken here
Tyler: Mine is corrupted!
Mark: *imitating* Mine's corrupted! *Ethan echoes "corrupted"* Someone has- has
tainted my bottle!
Mark: Fucking no! Ah, there we go.
Ethan: Oh noo your-your flip
*strange accent* Flip executed perfectly!
It's ok Courage-  SH!! SH! Sh! It's ok now...
Ethan: Live up to your name!
Mark: Only dreams, no nighmaures
*normal voice* Do doot doot do doot do!
SHING!
Mark: Mine's done!
Mark: d-dude you've  gotten a crevice Ethan: I know
Mark: What is THAT?
What is THAT?!?
Ethan: Ooh, time to flip!
Mark: Whoo no, no *Through giggles* NOOOohahhahahaho!!
Ethan: Courage, No!
Mark: COURAGE, NOOOO!
Mark: As you can see-
*Tyler laughs*
Mark: That's Kirby! *Ethan laughs*
Mark: You made an actually decent Kirby!
*Tyler and Ethan giggle*
Mark: You made a surprisingly good Kirby!
Ethan: Kirby the Cowardly Dog.
Mark: *through giggles* WHAT IS THAT!?
Ethan: IT'S COURAGE!
Mark: You didn't- you didn't-
even make a pancake!
Ethan: Yeah, I did!
Ethan: It tastes great!
Mark: So as you can see,
*Ethan giggles*
Mark: Courage,
Mark: Kirby... *Mark giggles*
Mark: Pretty good, huh!?
Not so bad, not so bad
Um, we'll, uh, we'll- we'll- we'll judge this later;
that's the initial first look;
we're gonna fill out our plate with multiple things
Um, you're just gonna have a pancake
And good choice with Tyler "The Apocalypse" Scheid.
He knows that Kirby is the most destructive force known to man, and
in all video game world there's no one more
sinister and more devastating- than Kirby.
Mark: Alright what is our next suggestion?
Amy: Squidward!
Mark: Squadward.
Tyler: That's a really good Squidward look
Mark: Thanks, we'll see how it turns when I - if I can flip this thing
I may need to borrow someone's spatula
Ethan: Y-your's looks like a d-*unintelligible* *Mark laughs *
Tyler: Mine is not- my stuff is not coming out of the freaking bottle!
Mark: Woah, woah
Ethan: Careful don't go on top of mine!
Mark: Oh shit- oh shit shit shit shit-
Ethan: guh, Mark!
Mark: shit, sorry! (Ethan: God dammit) sorry, I've ruined yours...
*Mark and Ethan giggles*
Mark: Oh-ho-ho jeez
Tyler: *laughing* jesus
It's like you're making an omelet. Just wait until it's done!
Tyler: I told you his, his is too liquidy.
Mark: Oh my GOD!
Oh yeah your's is,
Ethan: There's too much liquid!!
Mark: that's your main problem, your batter is off.
Mark: It looks like dog vomit... *Ethan laughs*
Tyler: Your's looks so good!
Mark: Thanks
Ethan: Tyler, how's mine look? *Mark laughs*
Tyler: Like I just took a dump.
Ethan: They are consistent.
Mark: They're so consistent.
Tyler: I had a hard time because my s-
my s-stuff isn't coming out
Mark: right, right, right, right.
Ethan: *laughing* Wait, Tyler, flip yours around
Tyler: No!
Ethan: Just Squidward.
Mark: Oh, yeah if you flip 'em around it's like the same thing!
Ethan: Mine are consistent, and so are yours.
Mark. And, uh, mine are Squidward and Courage the Cowardly Dog!
Mark: Yeah
Ethan: So are mine.
M: So uh, yeah that was pretty good!
Last one?
Tyler: I had no idea how to draw Squidward I'm bad from... memory
Mark: Alright, what is the last chal-adge ?
Amy: Homer Simpson
Mark: Homer Simpson?
Amy: Or any Simpson
Nah do Homer
Amy: A Simpson
Ethan: *coughs*
A s- a Simpson?
Amy: A Simpson!
Marge?
Mark: I'll do Homer
Ethan: Okay
Ethan: *softly* Peaceful time, making pancakes with you guys.
Mark: It's relaxing.
Good change from our normal- *laughing* fucking insane things that we do
I just want to take the time to say that I really love making videos with you guys,
like, it's, it's some of the greatest joys of my week
to be able to come together to watch you
fail, and you succeed but in the wrong way.
Ethan: I like how you're using your finger to draw.
Ethan: *genuinely* it's really inspiring.
Mark: You may fail, but you fail it in- in- in- in a wonderful way.
Ethan: Aw, thank you.
Aah
Ethan: *incredulously* Ch- you're really good at making pancakes
*Markigiggles*
Mark: I love making pancakes.
One of the-- One of the most
cherished times uh, when I was growing up was, umm
my dad made pancakes every single Sunday
and he loved pancakes, he- he- it was like a cherished tradition of ours
every Sunday morning we'd have
pancakes and he would start preparing em
on Saturday cuz he would have them sitting
overnight
in the uh- in the fridge so just kind of like
cooking and getting ready, and they were just the best pancakes, I've never had any other
pancake from any other place that was NEARLY as good as my dad's pancakes.
That's Ethan's,
Mine
*Tyler burp*
Pretty good alright, my first attempt at making art, I-I've never made pancake art before so
Ty: I like how you didn't use any color
M: Yeah, well I mean that's how, like traditional pancakes are usually done
you have to use the amount of cook
well that's not bad I can definitely see it, you got thick outline goin here-
Ethan: I think my issue was the batter than I made
Mark: Yeah, your batter was shit
Tyler: Well, it was- I was trying to fill it in
and it's hard when I don't have the squeeze to fill it in
Mark: I think you had the right amount of
like baking soda because yours are thicker
mine's are a bit thin probably a lil bit chewy but uh
Ethan: Mine are just right *Ethan and Mark giggle*
Mark: Your's are perfect the crust on your's, WHOO
so it comes down to this-
there are three categories of judgment
Number one, quality of the pancake itself,
outside of art how does it taste,
is it close to a pancake
And number two how close is the art
to the actual thing that was supposed to be
Like if it's Courage, Homer and Squidward,
How *Markigiggles* close
were they to the actual inspiration. And number three
taste, how does it taste, which tastes the best,
bar none, what tastes the best
Okay? Make sense? And
that's how we're going to need it but-
we have impartial judgeeeeeeeees
Kathryn and Amy: ♪Tuh tuh tuh tuh tuh tuh♪
Tyler: Who's tasting the pan-
Amy: You guys
Tyler: no 'cause we're, biased-
Amy: I'm not doing it!
Mark: Wait no, there are three pancakes, one for each of us, we trade out which
one of which, you can have Courage
Ethan: Mm-hm
I'll take your Courage
Ethan: You can have Squidward
Mark: Thanks
Tyler: Ethan you trade with my
Ethan: Tyler
Tyler: And Homer
Ethan: Uh, wait sorry, uh no this one was Homer
Mark:*laughing*
Mark: And now this works out so we each got one of these
we'll start with artistic interpretation like which one
do you guys think was closest to the
art
Tyler: Mark.
Ethan: Uh-
Tyler: This is Courage we're starting with Courage
Ethan: We're starting with Courage?
Tyler: I-I'm voting, I'm voting Mark just
based upon the plate,
Mark: Yeah I-I really wish i could see Courage out
of this one, but I just see Kirby.
Ethan: *laughing* There's a little Squidward in there, too!
Mark: Ho my god, that's an amazingly good Squidward in there!
Oh man if this is Squidward, I would say like Squidward in the
middle of the pink force but- no, I gotta give
it to myself too, yeah
Eeh, for Squidward!
*Mark ponders the blackened mass before him as Ethan laughs at the mess he has created*
Tyler: Obviously it's between Mark and me,
and Mark is definitely the winner
Ethan: I don't know about that
Mark: Yeah I don't know about this man, have you seen it Ethan: I've got some color in there!
Mark: Mmm- *laughing* smells like Squidward!
*Mark and Ethan giggle*
So, Homer Simpson *affirmative Ethan noise* I actually gotta give
a l- a little credit to this one I could see
Homer because what I was trying to do was, I was-
you were doing the same thing-
I was trying to make- that mouth is brown- and I was trying to make that different,
I can see the mouth distinctly better
it's just seemed like a rest of it got a little lost...
Tyler: I- I- I overflowed it at the end
Mark: Ethan's!
Tyler: I mean Ethan's...
I mean you can see the eye right there,
Mark: Yeah, the mouth,
the anger, the drinking problem like, I can see it
Ethan: You did a good job with the hair on yours I gotta give you props for that.
Mark: Oh thank you, I didn't know if that would turn out, but...
Tyler: I think, I think
overall Mark wins the artistic category. 100%
Mark: Aww, thank you, thank you.
So by texture though-
and I think we'll just go overall on this one-
'cause it was just the batter, and batter the same
I gotta give it to Tyler, because this is more l-light
Ethan: Yeah
Mark: It looks more like a pancake
mine are very thin, his is- pancake-like
Ethan: Mine are very- uh...
Mark: BUT- *Mark and Ethan giggle*
/again/, we gotta like, look at Ethan's
Tyler: This reminds me of like
crepe- crepe thinness, it's extra eggy
Mark: This is a thick crepe *laughs*
Tyler: Not, not that one!
Mark: Squidward's a thick crepe here-
Tyler: I'm going with this one, like the crispiness,
Mark: He is the crust, it's Ethan the-
you are very close to me *various Ethan noises/laughter*
I would give it to Tyler for the pancakeness of this  Ethan: I- I agree.
Mark: He's got the batter down.
Ethan: Ya
Now, here comes the hard part-
Ethan: *interrupts* Taste
Mark: Taste
Tyler: Alright- we have to try without syrup and then with syrup
Mark: Okay, w-we're just gonna go through each person's
Ethan: I think that we
should do a blind tastetest
Mark: We'd know. Tyler: We'd know.
Tyler: We'd totally know
Mark: Alright
Take Ethan's, alright, cheers
Tyler: Cheers. Clink-ies!
Mark: It's very sweet!
Tyler: It is very sweet.
Mark: It's very sweet.
Tyler: I do appreciate it.
Mark: It's light, It's fluffy, It is fluffy-
like, it is not bad
Tyler: Got a nice crisp to it,
Mark: It's not a bad one, it's just
weird 'cause like in the middle it's kinda goopy
Ethan: *laughs*
Tyler: Mine doesn't, you just have the thick one
Mark: I've the thick one, yeah
But this is not bad
Tyler: Here try this one.
Mark: I- I just don't mind this
Tyler: I do not mind this at all
It is pleasant. It is not bad. Not /pancake/ but-
Tyler: I would- I would eat it. To Mark?
Mark: Alright, let's try me.
Ethan: Your's are a little bit bland
Mark: Little bland, Definitely a little bland,
Tyler: But definitely pancake tasting,
like texture
Mark: This is the one that could use syrup,
like you- you definitely want syrup on it
Tyler: Yeah, this is definitely a syrup one *affirmative Mark noise*
Tyler: Okay
Mark: Ok not bad, m- pancakey, not as sweet-
which may or may not be good- but
in my mind I- I still like Ethan's better
Tyler: Alright
Ethan: So we got a little sweet,
little bland, will Tyler be right in the middle?
Mark: It's a little chewy
Tyler: A little chewy
Mark: I would say, just a little chewy
Tyler: It's got good flavor
Mark: Not bad yeah, it's sweeter than mine, chewy but-
Tyler: It's like it didn't fluff quite enough
Mark: Yeah I thought it was gonna be fluffier just because of the way it is, but it
turned out thicker, not bad,
but weirdly enough I gotta give it to Ethan.
Tyler: I- I- me too, it tastes good
Mark: It looks bad, it tastes good
Ethan: Thanks guys!
Mark: Yeah. That's a point for everybody
Ethan: That is a point for everyone
Mark: We all win
Tyler: We're all winners
I already ate my pancakes so I like-
Mark: I eat mine but I'm eating Ethan's.
Tyler: I'm eating Ethan's too.
Mark: It was all that sugar that just *all laughing* BOOM, FUCK
Tyler: Like superblast.
*mouth full* I think they all taste good in my umfuffinum
Mark: I think we all are winners in our own way, I had the artistic interpretation,
you had the pancakey look and feel of it,
and you had taste overall
I like it! That worked out really well, I mean not
every competition has to end in
bloodshed and terror
Ethan: No
Tyler: *stabs at Mark with spatula*
Tyler: I would never stab you with a spactula *Mark and Ethan laugh*
Mark: *laughing* Thanks, Tyler!
Thank you for that, awww that means so much to me
So, anyway that is the end of the
pancake challenge we hope you guys
enjoyed this we have a lot of fun making it,
we have a lot of fun doing this, and
from Ethan "the Crust" Nestor to Tyler "the Apocalypse"- *laughing*
"the 12 Apocalypses" Scheid
and me Mark "Mr. Butterworth" Fischbach.
And I expect excellent fan art of that name in the future
Tyler: If you guys wanna make pancakes, pancake art
Mark: Oh yeah! *affirmative noise*
Tyler: We would love to see it, send it to us tag us, instagram, twitter,
Mr. Butterworth: Mr Butterworth.
Tyler: Put it in the comments
Mark: Yeah so just let us know if you guys wanna do this
it is really easy to do, you just get a
squeeze bottle, put pancake mix, and just time it up
so either way, thank you everybody so much for watching,
and as always we will see you
In the next video
BUH-BYE
Tyler & Ethan: Byeeee